have you bought bitcoin since the last
time i was on you know i had bought
bitcoin when it was
in the early very early the the
whatever 10 bitcoins i had got hacked
because the
back then there were no exchanges really
there was no
uh you know there weren't a lot of
exchanges so that got hacked and i
probably lost 10 bitcoins
uh and then my wife had bought a bunch
when it was at
300 or 800 dollars so we're massively up
on that
i haven't bought more and the
i've actually thought about just putting
one percent of my net worth into bitcoin
um because of the hedge you talk about
the thing i've been impressed about and
has evolved my thinking on bitcoin
is that it has not been hacked
or had like you know a 51 attack or
any i mean i know it's been manipulated
i know it's anonymous or
pseudo-anonymous so there's all these
you know edge cases but the fact that a
government
hasn't been able to either shut it down
um or uh you know uh
hack it explicitly i know they can hack
you know your wallet or
hack coinbase or spoof you but the fact
that the core has not
been compromised to me is just
extraordinary why there's so much at
stake
in hacking bitcoin the fact that it
hasn't been hacked
to me is phenomenal it's the number one
target in the world correct
so i would separate this in two pieces
one is
there is an argument that hacking the
actual protocol itself
would ruin all the value right so the
second that somebody goes and hacks it
like the 200 billion dollars of market
value goes to zero
right because it's no longer unhackable
but with that said um i've had a lot of
success talking especially to
institutional investors about this
but i think a lot of technology
investors get it as well so
if i said to you uh hey i want to own
part of google's search algorithm right
you would say go buy google stock
if i said to you i want to own facebook
social network you'd say go buy facebook
stock
correct if i said to you i want to own
the strongest computing network in the
world which is the bitcoin network
you would say go buy but there's no
corporation to go buy there's no equity
and so what you have to do to get
financial exposure is you have to buy
bitcoin itself right and so part of what
i think is really interesting here
is there was a very long period of time
where
maybe a couple people in silicon valley
were into this but really
for the most part a lot of people missed
bitcoin
in terms of the amount of capital that
could have been put into it right some
people got personal exposure or whatever
but when you think of it as just the
strongest computing network in the world
and i ask people like what's that worth
i don't think you and i are going to be
good at putting a
future value on that but if it remains
the strongest computing network in the
world
i think it's worth trillions of dollars
at a minimum right and so
to put some exposure into it um i think
just
is generally a good practice yeah
my thesis was this is the what i came to
in
over the last couple of years since it
did not get hacked and it's still stable
um i said to my and we had people on
this podcast talking about bitcoin when
it was
under a dollar so just to be clear i
mean i've been tracking this forever
my belief the last couple years has been
majority chances it goes down to zero or
you know low hundreds of dollars and
gets replaced by a better technology
because that's what always happens
almost universally some technology gets
replaced now there are some
that have not that have become built to
last
email as an open protocol has and the
web
um rss kind of got deprecated because
google gave up on reader
and so it doesn't always happen that way
and ftp and gopher and send and all
these usenet
other things that were open protocols
haven't gone away or just are not used
all that often
but it feels it felt to me like the
second somebody made something better
than bitcoin
you know really better and that also had
the increase
in value then it would be game over for
bitcoin because the people who were
uh hodlers and were holding holders
they would say you know what i want to i
want to do what i did with bitcoin
i want to go 10x i want to go 1000x so
i'm going to move my exposure over here
and that would
start this you know degradation of the
price
right and nobody would buy it because
there was no upside so why hasn't that
happened because i still think that's
i would put it at 50 50 that that's what
happens
that analysis would be dead on except
for one thing
this isn't a technology problem it's a
money thing
and so you have to remember is money is
a belief system like why
do why would you take dollars from me
and i take dollars from you because we
both believe that dollar has value
now the best way to highlight the
difference and what
you just said and what i think bitcoin
provides is
if you're in a country where your nation
state
currency fails like it literally
hyperinflation the whole nine yards
and then the the government comes to you
and says hey jason sorry that that
happened
uh but we got this new currency that we
created just use this one
you are very very unlikely to believe
them on the second one
right you they violated your trust and
so
when i think of bitcoin what i think of
is we we being
the citizens of the world get one shot
to separate state and money one shot at
it that is bitcoin
if it happens tens of trillions if not
hundreds of trillions of dollars in
value
if it doesn't happen bitcoin goes to
zero and there will not be a replacement
because it has too much momentum and too
much buy-in at this point it has kind of
the the mental
um kind of capture this is the shot to
separate state and money
and so when i think of it that way it's
if bitcoin was to fail
i actually don't think people would buy
into the next one
uh mentally because it would say oh you
can never separate state and money
right there's too many people who are
seeing this for the first time and so
it's like
we get one shot you know hey all you
speculators that are speculating in the
public market stuff don't go put 100 of
your assets into bitcoin
but also don't get caught having zero
exposure
right i think that's
i i think that's a pretty good analysis
actually um
and maybe i'll just after this podcast
go put one percent into bitcoin
what is it wasn't this suppose this is a
question i have for you
um wasn't a world-changing event
a world shattering event supposed to be
the moment where bitcoin shined well we
just went through this crazy pandemic
that i think is the definition of that a
global shutdown that like none we've
seen
and there was supposed to be this
massive flight into it
and then there was this other reason
that y'all kept saying was oh you guys
are printing so much money
right money printer goes burr or
whatever that meme you guys have and you
fight your wars and memes
which i think the vc community needs to
learn from we got to get better at meme
warfare
in the investment community here in
silicon valley um
but um why didn't bitcoin
spike over the last you know
year i mean i know it was at like 6 000
and went up to whatever seven or
something
uh or actually maybe it's at nine so
shouldn't it have gone crazy or no
so let's go back in history to
understand what's happening now
in 2008 uh when the financial crisis hit
gold which is widely considered a store
of value um
it went down 30 over the summer of 2008.
and the reason is there was a liquidity
crisis so people looked around their
portfolios and said the world's ending
all chaos is broken loose
i want to sell any asset that's got a
liquid market to it and so they sold
everything right they sold stocks they
sold gold
scared people yeah and so in response to
that liquidity crisis the federal
reserve printed at the time hundreds of
billions of dollars
right and then gold 2xed in value from
there ended up hitting an all-time high
in 2011.
what we just saw so far and are still in
i would argue
is there was a liquidity crisis starting
in march where people looked around the
room and sold everything right i mean
bitcoin went down 50 percent in one day
at one point right stocks went down 30
gold went down 15 all this stuff but if
you look from the beginning of this year
to now bitcoin is up 30 35
it's actually the best performing asset
of all the asset classes
right it's better than most commodities
better than stocks etc
and so what it's doing is it's hyper
volatile
and the best comparison i think is if
you look at like amazon
right so amazon's been one of the best
performing stocks since it went public
it's gone down double digits every
single year it's been public
and the average intra-year drawdown of
amazon stock is 30 plus percent
one time it went down over 90 percent in
a a time period and so when you look at
that amazon stock's been hyper volatile
but it's also led to incredible growth
a lot of innovation it's been one of the
best performing stocks bitcoin looks
very similar in the sense that it's
hyper volatile
when there's times of liquidity crisis
all assets trend towards a correlation
of one
bitcoin went down but on the rebound
where we see the federal reserve
printing all this money bitcoin has
performed all of their assets
and so if you look at somebody like a
paul tudor jones his argument is look
i believe central banks are going to
continue to print trillions of dollars
and inject liquidity into the global
economy
i want to own what he called the the
fastest horse
and he believes that to be bitcoin so he
put two percent of his assets a couple
hundred million dollars
into bitcoin and said i think that this
is just gonna outperform everything else
the central banks just pump these assets
to the moon
when will bitcoin hit a new all-time
high and under and what would be the
likely scenario that would cause it to
do that
so because what was the time 20 000 yeah
all-time high's a little hard but what i
will say is and i've said publicly a
couple times is
uh in 2017 all of these
um kind of models right if you think of
how is price determined at supply and
demand
the advantage bitcoin has over all other
assets is that you know with 100
certainty you can verify how many
bitcoin exists and how many are coming
in in the daily supply
so gold for example you kind of sort of
know how much exists you kind of sort of
know how much being produced on a daily
basis
but with bitcoin you know 100 fact so
really what you've got to be able to do
is
uh model out or forecast demand and if
bitcoin's demand
continues to grow how it has for the
last decade it was supposed to hit 10
000
in december in 2017 and it's supposed to
hit a hundred thousand dollars by the
end of 2021.
in obviously 2017 we saw it go from ten
thousand
over ten thousand to twenty thousand
dollars it went from ten thousand to
twenty thousand in eighteen days
in q4 of 2017. yeah that was like the
holidays like thanksgiving just
and december i remember my wife was like
it's a blow off top
yeah it was incredible and i was like
sell it
i spoke at that crypto conference down
at the santa monica
uh airport and i said listen i know a
lot of you bought this
nonsense for a hundred bucks and you
tried 20 000 now
please sell half because this
never happens in the world that you have
a
10x 20x 200x in this period of time
i know you think it's gonna go 200 from
here please sell half
and buy a house and nobody did it
maybe some people did it i don't know i
guess they had to be somebody on the
other side of the trade right
yeah what i think happens is it went to
20 000 it was there for like
i don't know 24 hours right it's not get
hung out there for a while
crash all the way down to around 3 000.
uh i think what will happen
over the next 18 months is we're gonna
see another massive bull market so we're
gonna see bitcoin
you know go hit a hundred thousand
dollars by the end of 2021
it's gonna be the same thing that you
saw in 2017. there's gonna be
mass chaos people aren't gonna sell
they're gonna be piling in and fomoing
and doing all this stuff
and so what ends up kind of happening is
like look markets are markets
right we've talked about how many
markets today where people fomo in and
they're speculating
so it's just kind of like you know you
can warn people as much as you want but
they're still going to speculate right
human nature takes over
and greed takes over